lucie manuel la nouvelle présidente de
l'association patronale contacter
l'entreprise est avec nous on sort qu'a
dit mon jour là la manuelle
bonjour mon idole tombe on jouera aux
auditeurs de la première
merci d'être avec nous quelques jours
seulement après cette élection et vous
avez succédé à emmanuel de reynal une
femme à la tête de contacter les femmes
de plus en plus visible est exposée est
ce une bonne chose mais si manuel
je pense que c'est une bonne chose dans
le sens où la société composée d'hommes
et de femmes et les normales qui est la
mixité au sein des organismes
représentatifs de cette société
actuellement il ya josiane calonnois la
caisse générale de sécurité sociale qui
a succédé d'ailleurs à les gêner liberia
josian caproens pays provisoirement
on a eu des directrices et des f&a
l'insee à pôle emploi
et pourtant on a l'impression que
beaucoup de ses fins même en premier
plan la chine y investir le champ
médiatique c'est par pudeur c'est par
timidité c'est aussi peut-être parce
qu'elle était dans un champ où
effectivement elle devait être tourné
vers l'action et pas forcément dans la
représentation c'est une énergie qui est
différente
en tout cas je pense qu'elles ont fait
des choses et c'est aussi peut-être
parce que il y a encore peut-être une
défiance mutuelle entre certains
écosystèmes entre les médias et
peut-être le monde entrepreunarial ou le
monde
voilà le monde institutionnel donc ce
sont des choses que nous un contact
entreprises on essaye de faire évoluer
pour que il ya effectivement plus de
prises de parole sur des gens qui
travaillent au quotidien et qui font des
belles choses pour la martinique qui
vous vous êtes issu de la communication
et les femmes doivent-elles se montrer
davantage
est-ce qu'il faut décloisonner tout cela
est ce que par exemple vous à la tête de
contact entreprises et demandé à
d'autres femmes de se monter de monter
au créneau
non je pense que c'est un parcours
individuel qui amène effectivement
certaines femmes à prendre des
responsabilités
on ne peut pas forcément être dans une
approche existe un entre femmes et
hommes
mais il ya des parcours personnels et il
a fallu forcer quand même
les portes de temps en temps il faut
forcer les portes de toute façon si on
veut effectivement atteindre ses
objectifs
pas forcément en tant que femme en tant
qu en tant qu'entrepreneur on est obligé
aussi de forcer certaines portes c'est
pas forcément liée au caractère féminin
de l'individu alors la présidence de
contact entreprises qui a voulu faire
connaître ce monde de l'entreprise et
être force de proposition qui sera votre
action je pense que nous allons nous
situer effectivement dans la continuité
des actions qui ont été déjà entreprises
l'objet de contact entreprises c'est de
promouvoir l'entreprise l'image de
l'entreprise en martinique
et donc c'est ce qui va guider notre
action nous allons donc continuer sur la
lancée de contact entreprises un large
panel d'actions
et puis nous allons également en
fonction des sollicitations que nous
allons recevoir des nouveaux besoins qui
vont émerger
nous allons aussi mettre en place des
nouvelles actions
je pense notamment dès vendredi nous
avons le premier séminaire risque
organisé par contact entreprises pour
les chefs d'entreprise qui a pour
objectif de les aider à mieux prévenir
et mieux gérer leur entreprise notamment
là on rentre en période cyclonique
voilà nous allons mettre en place des
nouvelles actions et gardez également
des formats qui qui fonctionne à mon
sens on vous a vu vous l'expliquer aux
auditeurs tout à l'heure on vous a
entendu tout ce qu'on vous a vu plutôt
être très attentif à ce que le disait
jean marc partie concernant cette
martinique entrepreneuriale de cette
jeunesse qui doit revenir de
l'attractivité de la martinique est ce
que vous avez à dire là dessus
l'attractivité c'est vraiment la
thématique prioritaire pour la
martinique
on l'a entendu effectivement il nous
sommes dans une situation démographique
qui est très alarmante
nous subissons une véritable hémorragie
démographique
nous avons d'ailleurs à contacter
l'entreprise menée mener des opérations
et édité un livre orange hashtag
martinique attractive cpournous
fondamental que que la martinique puisse
s'emparer effectivement de cette
thématique et au niveau des entreprises
effectivement je pense qu'il ya des
choses à faire parce que l'entreprise
c'est le pivot aussi du développement et
donc de l'attractivité de la martinique
de demain donc à la fois pour faire
revenir nos jeunes talents leur proposer
des emplois qui soient à la mesure de
leur formation mais également pour
développer nos atouts il faut une
dynamique entrepreneuriale pour pouvoir
bien développé nation sur quels leviers
vous aimeriez voir les choses bouger
davantage pour la rendre attractive
cette martinique est pour l'instant le
flux les dans l'autre sens pour la
rendre attractive
il y a bailly à l'emploi c'est quand
même un pivot fondamentale l'emploi
proposer des emplois aux jeunes qui
reviennent dans un territoire ou hulu la
courbe du chômage frôle des jeunes frôle
les 50%
c'est important effectivement que l'on
puisse avoir des entreprises plus forte
qu'ils puissent qu'ils puissent proposer
un panel d'emploi et un volume d'emplois
nécessaires pour les jeunes et pour
qu'ils puissent revenir en martinique ça
c'est déjà un premier un premier atout
en tout cas un premier point la mobilité
aussi c'est un c'est une thématique qui
est importante la mobilité interne au
territoire
c'est un frein c'est un frein réel pour
pouvoir développer les entreprises il
faut que nous soyons doter
d'infrastructures routières ou de
transport qui permet aux rétro festival
rendez vous qui permet de voir qu'ils
permettent effectivement de retrouver de
la fluidité au niveau du territoire
et puis c'est également à les explorer
de nouveaux champs économiques je pense
notamment à l'économie numérique qui
pourrait être vraiment intéressant au
niveau de la martinique de pouvoir
développer ce pan de l'économie parce
qu'effectivement nous sommes un petit
territoire mais doté de jeunes qui sont
très formée de jeunes qui s'intéressent
au numérique
il y a un fort dynamisme
des start-up heures en martinique et là
il ya effectivement un champ à
l'explorer alors vous reparler de cette
image de l'entreprise que au sein de
votre association vous cherche à
développer
est ce qu'il ya des réticences parce que
si vous êtes président depuis une
quinzaine de jours à peu près s'il est
ce qu'il ya des réticences à vouloir
comprendre ce monde en entreprise en
martinique des réticences en tout cas le
constat est qu'il y a encore un gap
entre la réalité des entreprises la
réalité du métier de chef d'entreprise
aussi et de ce qu'est l'entreprise il y
à un gap entre cette réalité et les
perceptions que l'on s'en fait il y a
encore des préjugés négatifs qui sont
qui ce qui repose souvent sur une
méconnaissance du monde de l'entreprise
et c'est un des axes forts du travail de
contact
c'est d'ouvrir l'entreprise c'est de
créer des passerelles entre le monde de
l'entreprise et d'autres écosystèmes
comment comment expliquer ce set
comment expliquer qu'on ne comprennent
pas qu'on me connaissent pas tous les
toutes les facettes du monde de
l'entreprise
lorsqu'on sort de l'établissent de
l'école on entend forcément dans une
entreprise entre des patrons qu'on
rencontre des collègues rencontre des
salariés
pourquoi on n'arrive toujours pas à
comprendre comment ça fonctionne alors
je ne sais pas si je pense que les
jeunes sont de plus en plus formés au
monde de l'entreprise
après on rentre dans une entreprise ou
pas on peut aussi on peut aussi choisir
d'autres voies on peut
je pense que c'est aussi aux entreprises
de communiquer d'ouvrir leurs portes
pour qu'effectivement de faire sans
marty deeks on le fait de plus en plus
au sein de contact on organise
énormément de visites d'entreprises pour
que justement on puisse sur le terrain
aller découvrir la réalité la réalité
des entreprises
le contact sont des prises de paroles
mais ce sont aussi des actions concrètes
avec des déjeuners débats où on va
inviter des personnes issues du monde
institutionnel ou politiques pour qu'il
y ait un échange franc entre le monde de
l'entreprise et tous ces écosystèmes qui
qui qui qui forment la société
martiniquaise et les secours ce même
d'une entreprise
tous les codes sont connus entre celui
qui dirige entre les salariés entre les
chefs de service par exemple je pense
qu'il ya encore effectivement du travail
à faire pour que la culture
entrepreunariale elles puissent aussi
s'épanouir au sein même de l'entreprise
là il ya une responsabilité du chef
d'entreprise aussi de pouvoir donner les
codes pour comprendre pour que
l'ensemble de l'équipe puisse comprendre
aussi comment fonctionne concrètement
une entreprise les besoins de
l'entreprise
des chaussures des notions assez simple
à quand un chiffre d'affaires c'est pas
forcément un bénéfice enfin sur des
notions assez simple qui a beaucoup
travaillé à faire beaucoup de travail en
tout cas je pense que c'est un travail
qui est assez passionnant et qui doit
conduire justement nos actions à
contacter ça peut être effectivement des
actions pour une meilleure connaissance
au sein même de l'entreprise mais
également au niveau du monde éducatif
vers les enseignants ce sont des choses
que nous souhaitons mettre en place
voilà il ya ya ya aussi au niveau des
cadres territoriaux et on est à
rencontre rencontrer les élus mais on a
peut-être aussi un travail à faire au
niveau des administratifs pour que
effectivement il ya une vraie
compréhension de la réalité même de
l'entreprise vrai peu près une
quarantaine d'années le 6 manuelle
vous êtes chef d'entreprise qu'est ce
que vous aimeriez dire par exemple à ses
élèves qui font qu'ils sont en train de
passer leur diplôme que c'est au collège
que ce soit au lycée que ce soit
l'université
vous avez envie de leur dire quoi que le
monde de l'entreprise c'est vraiment
quelque chose de magique
je pense que l'épanouissement
professionnel ne passe pas forcément par
le monde de l'entreprise mais qu'en tout
cas s'il y a des volonté de porter des
projets s'il y a si ces jeunes en des
ondes et des projets des rêves
il faut un peu d'audace il faut que nous
aussi en tant que chef d'entreprise déjà
établies on puisse les soutenir il ya
des associations qui le font très bien
martinique je pense notamment à réseau
entreprendre
il faut avec une nouvelle dirigeante que
je salue il y a également au niveau des
institutionnels des politiques il y a
vraiment une dynamique de cohésion à
mettre en place pour aider ces jeunes
qui vont rentrer sur le marché de
l'emploi dans quelques années à aller au
bout de leur rêve que ce soit des rêves
entrepreneuriaux ou voilà d'autres
projets leurs filles de tous ces frais
par exemple financement du projet je
pense qu'il ya vraiment effectivement à
permettre à la martinique de libérer son
potentiel entrepreneurial et que tous
les aspects qui concernent la mise en
place de projets de financement soit
optimale et fonctionne correctement
merci d'avoir été ce lot avec nos lucie
manuel toute nouvelle présidente de
l'association patronale contacter
l'entreprise merci d'envoyer dans son
caddie